Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on.
Guys. This is Rob and we are back again with another installment of our,
how to kill superhero series, where as the name implies,
we figure out how to bring about the demise of our favorite superheroes or
supervillains.
And the character that we're discussing today has been both a hero and a villain
at various times, but whichever side of the spectrum he falls on,
he is without a doubt,
one of the strongest characters in DC comics and a character that has been
brought back to the forefront recently with the events of dark nights, metal,
we're forced talking about Superboy Prague,
but before we figure out how to kill what is certainly one of the most powerful
versions of Superman, we'll go over his origin and his powers.
So the character that would become super boy prime was created by Elliot S Magen
and Curt Swan. And first appeared in DC comics presents number 87 in 1985,
although he would not adopt the moniker of Superboy prime until much later in
2006 is infinite crisis. Number two.
So the character is actually the Superman of earth prod,
which is basically DC universe's version of the earth that we live in.
Meaning that just like on our earth superheroes are not real.
They're simply just characters in comic books, movies, and television shows.
But on that earth,
we get a version of Khalil coming to earth from the planet Krypton.
And he's adopted by the Kens as a child.
And given the name Clark now Clark grows up normally until the age of 15,
when Halley's comet passes over the earth,
which activates Clark's latent Kryptonian powers,
which are all basically the same powers as Superman has superhuman strength,
superhuman speed in vulnerability flight x-ray vision. You guys get the deal.
No one earth prime is destroyed by the auntie monitor during the crisis on
infinite source event,
Superboy battles alongside heroes from other earth to defeat him.
And once the auntie monitor is vanquished,
Superboy goes to a paradise dimension along with earth,
two versions of Superman and Lois lane, as well as Alexander Luther,
the son of Lex Luther from earth three. Now, while in this dimension,
Superboy prime never actually ages,
but becomes embittered by the fact that he was robbed of his childhood and would
never grow up to fulfill his destiny of becoming Superman.
He also comes to hate the new earth version of super boy,
Connor Kent for filling the role that he felt was rightfully his.
And so during his many years in this pocket dimension,
just getting matter in matter,
Alexander Luther decides that they've all had enough and they're going to make
their way to the DC universe.
And so Superboy prime starts punching the barrier between the two realities,
which not only causes the barrier to break down,
but also sends ripple effects throughout reality, altering it in several ways,
such as bringing dead characters back to life. Furthermore,
he proves himself to be powerful enough to alter the orbits of planets,
as well as change the location of the center of the universe.
Not only was Superboy prime,
able to best Martian Manhunter a character on par with Superman in terms of
power, but was also able to punch his way out of the Phantom zone,
which up to that point was thought to be impossible. And which once again,
set reality altering ripple effects throughout the universe.
He's also said to be faster than Wally West,
who's considered to be the fastest of all the speedsters at the time and was
able to free himself from the speed force,
despite being exposed constant red sun radiation,
which dampen his powers during his time in the speed force.
His powers are augmented even further. As he created a conduit for himself,
the captured and store the energy of yellow suns from which his powers are
derived. Following this,
he was able to easily defeat the combined forces of the justice society,
the team Titans, the justice league and the doom patrol.
And so it should be clear by now that super-wide prime is not only one of the
strongest versions of Superman that's ever existed,
but it's also one of the most powerful characters in all of comics.
And so with that in mind, the question becomes, how do we kill them? Well,
first we need to address two major ways that will not be successful because
super boy prime is a version of Superman.
It might seem obvious to use Superman's traditional weakness against him.
The most widely known weakness of Superman is of course, kryptonite,
you could ask anyone that has never even picked up a comic book,
and they could likely tell you that kryptonite is Superman's weakness.
It's that ingrained in pop culture that while kryptonite does have devastating
effects on Superman, Superboy prime does not share that weakness.
The reason for this is that in his universe,
there were no fragments of his home planet,
Krypton that survived the destruction of the planet.
And the fragments of Krypton from other universes are not fumble to him.
And so kryptonite is not going to help us in any way.
Another weakness of Superman's is magic.
There have been countless times throughout history that this has been exploited
and it's well-established to be a part of his character. But once again,
this information is useless in our attempt to take out super boy prime because
he does not share this weakness either.
We have to remember that super boy prime comes from earth prime,
which is the analog to our world. So just like in our world,
magic does not exist there.
And so boy prime is not going to be vulnerable against it.
And so that's off the table as well. Now,
simply overwhelming Superboy prime is also not likely to give us the result that
we want when one of the guardians of the universe tries to destroy himself by
self-destructing Superboy prime simply absorbed the resulting energy,
and it only made it more powerful,
at least powerful enough to destroy an entire universe and kidnap Mr. Mixel.
Pedalec one of the strongest reality wipers in DC comics.
And so we can't just produce a powerful enough attack to take him out either.
And so we're going to have to figure out some weakness to exploit. Now,
if you were paying attention earlier,
I mentioned that when Superboy prime was stuck in the speed force,
he was constantly being exposed to red sun radiation, which dampened Ms. Powers.
However,
this did not seem to be overly effective since he was able to not only survive,
but build a suit that harnessed yellow sun energy and escape, the speed force,
which also would have been impossible.
But I think that clues us in to our answer here.
And that is for that as powerful as Superboy prime is he still relies on yellow
sun energy to survive.
And so we're going to need to find a way to cut them off from the supply of
stored yellow sun energy that is supervised.
And we're also going to have to block his access to any additional sunlight.
If we can do those two things,
he should theoretically be no harder to kill than the average person since
Kryptonians do not have super powers on Krypton due to the absence of a yellow
sun nearby. And so I think that's our best bet.
We're going to have to disrupt his connection with his power suit and also find
a way to block the sun's radiation from reaching the battlefield in order to be
successful. But let me know what you guys think,
but if you could think of a better way to take out Superboy prime,
let me know down in the comment section.
If you guys are new here to come as explain,
make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a light.
Now we'll catch you all later.
Bruce.